وينه وانا في السجن زميل لقيت بزاري
القادم من مونديال قطر مراسل صباح العربيه
اهلا بك يا ليث يعطيك العافيه كنت عين
صباح العربيه في قلب الحدث مونديال قطر
حدثنا اكثر عن تجربه
فريده صباح الخير لكم اولا فريده اول شيء
اول مره بتاريخ المونديال يقام في مدينه
مش في بلد كان بس بالدوحه المونديال عاده
المونديال يقام بعده مدن او في عده بلدان
بس هالمره كان في الدوحه وابعد الناس
فكروا انه راح تكون ازمه وزحام ومش عارف
شو طلعت القصه كلها مكسيما من وسط الدوحه
من سوق واقف لابعد استاد اللي هو البيت
نصف ساعه بالسياره
بلش بالخضر اول ما وصلنا كان يوم السبت
مباراه
الخضار منتخب السعودي فما لقيت غير
هالشباب جايين عليك
[موسيقى]
وقالوا لي لحظه احنا مشفقنا عليه شباب
بريده بدي احييها وينكم
نايف وتركي وسعود تحيه لكم لانهم عنجد من
القصيم
للمنتخب السعودي
انخل دي ماريال سجل الهدف فانا شافني دي
ماريا قلت له طلع هو انا بعمله هيك فكر
انه ارميلي شغله ما لقيت غير ميسي
على المباشر مبدانا نسيطر على الموضوع بس
اكثر شيء عنجد اثر في شغل ثاني مره من
المرات واحنا باحد المباشرات واذا شاب
سوداني مجلى عندي ما لقيته غير وهو بيحكي
منفعل اليوم ما ربح الفريق جبال سلسله
الاطلس
الخضراء المنتخب المغربي الاسود الاطلس ما
لقيتهم غير جنبي ما شفت غير شفافه بتحرك
بطريقه قلت لها في دمع بعيونك وبكي على
الهواء هيك كثير مؤثره قال شوف كيف
المونديال جمع العرب كيف خلانا شعب واحد
كيف رفع معنويات العرب في حادث رياضيه
عالميه هذا كثير حلو
كثير مباشر
في راح اتكنك كده بس نخسر عملت الاسكار
قالت كل مره بس اطلع من الملعب اذا ربحاني
راح اخليه معك اذا خسرنا بهديك اياه باحد
المباشرات ولا هي جايه بتقول لي خسرنا
اليوم
فهذا كيا كان كثير مؤثر وهاي في شاب
فلسطيني عرف اني عاشق فرنسا قال لي عندي
وحده الك الريف بالستايل وعالم فرنسا
وعالم فلسطين بنفس العلم بنفس اللفحه او
الاسكارف
يعني كثير اثرت فينا وبتضل اكيد في شغلات
كثيره صارت معنا بس للاسف مش موافقه
بالصور او بالفيديو
نحاول نيموكن باللايفات ولا لا
نحاول يعني مرات يكون صعب خصوصا لما يكون
حدث عربي او مع المنتخب السعودي او
المنتخب المغربي كانت كثير نشتغل على قصص
اللايف ونحاول نجيب
هيك قصص طريفه غريبه فريده فكانت حلوه
تفضل
مباراه يعني حسيت انه يا ريت انا مش رايح
بمهامه شغل يا ريت انا رايح كسايح بدي
اروح على قطر المباراه الي بحبها واستمتع
بس
المغرب وفرنسا كنت اتمنى وفي لحظه من
اللحظات احد من اللاعبات بتذكر مع العيال
بالليل همم
البوابه مباشر
اهم احنا نشوفها
كحياه شخصيه يعني كمشاهده شخصيه
مميزه للمونديال شكرا جزيلا دائما لكم